Lord we thank you for this day and
please protect us from anything that
might lead or affect us astray kids make
sure you read your Bibles it's the best
word you can be watching nothing with
the S word okay
you know it breaks my heart our culture
is of course in Clinton was to start and
eight years more Deb you need to get
back to the tenets of song govern mess
that is why I came to here and watch
I'll stay the school likes to grab crash
so give me more disclosure of
entitlement proposals I used to say we
can't afford pack my training close the
border use crude language the exposure
that up till now I aboard while I'm not
a total poseur you could say I'm getting
closer you look at all you people out
here nodding when there's going to be a
lot of bombings we grieve Trump that guy
just gives the pot of stirring motion I
haven't seen such terrible emotion since
New Year's Eve you know it breaks my
heart the wars are never-ending George
Bush was the start and
Dontrelle Mike Pence we need to stop the
droning is to come and sense those are
things all protest and scream unless you
know it hurts my team so hand me opening
poster because now my band of poser of
the farming's and the war that for eight
years I glossed over my memory is a
selective as Meryl Streep I suppose has
that felt we brought them older you
could say I'm getting closer you could
say we're getting closer you could say
we're getting closer
[Music]